what's up believe nation welcome to
season three of million dollar
businesses where i break down what it
takes to build a million dollar plus
business in different industries this
season we look at the life coaching
industry where i sit down with tim's
story and we go over his 10 keys to
success to building a lucrative life
coaching business tim has traveled to 75
countries to council high profile
leaders entrepreneurs artists and
athletes he's authored multiple
best-selling books he's been a featured
guest on oprah's super soul sunday if
you want to learn how to be a successful
life coach this is the man you want to
learn from let's go meet him and pick
his brain together
when you talk about life coach whoa or
life advisor you're taking somebody's
life in your hands
and so i think it's very very important
to
become educated in what it means to
coach somebody in their life be careful
man you got people's lives in your hands
so i i literally keep my phone on 24
hours
a day because you know i've had i've had
13 people die on me
in the last year
they died
so it's no joke to me but this is all
real stuff
so it's not like oh man i'm a coach i'm
out there making money
no people are dying
so we've saved a lot of lives and we
lost lives so it's serious stuff
mr tim's story thanks for having me in
your home man really appreciate it good
to see you i'm loving what you're
wearing this is it this is fresh
but what's the logo all about the logo
well this is about you but i'll quickly
tell you the logo the logo is a paper
airplane yeah to me represents
entrepreneurship so entrepreneurs we
take off ooh right so we got we have a
dream we want to fly we want to take off
but
but it's a paper airplane because we
don't have the money the resources
are the the wings are hitting we're not
this jet plane taking off right away but
we we want to be i like it right it's
working yeah so so instead of doing a
fist pump what i do is we do this we do
this believe it's the airplane taking
off boom there there it is i like it
i love it so we're doing a 10-part
series to talk about how to have a
success
in the life coaching business
point number one for you was get
educated yes so what does that mean to
you well i think that you know before
you
get out there and share your knowledge
you got to get knowledge right
and and i think that
i always say it this way just because
you can sing
[Music]
doesn't mean that you should be a
professional singer okay so just because
you're smart doesn't mean you should be
a life coach
because when you talk about life coach
whoa
or life advisor you're taking somebody's
life in your hands
and so i think it's very very important
to
become educated in what it means to
coach somebody in their life
so my my background is i have a doctrine
in world religion
but while i was studying that i took
probably seven years of training
in uh marriage and family crisis
counseling
so really i i am a therapist
so that that helped me to deal with
people's lives because as you know you
got your physical life your spiritual
life your financial life your job
then you have your uh
social life so depending on what
somebody's going through i feel like
because of my education
i'm more equipped to handle
whatever they're going through so what
do you think somebody who wants to be a
life coach should do for their own
education how do we get educated okay so
one thing is your story is your story so
i i do believe that
somebody can have an amazing story of
coming from addiction
and then getting better and then they
can coach people in in that field
or someone that was an athlete
and they went from being an athlete and
and then they'd
no more applause for the crowd they
could coach somebody having to do with
that
but i think it's it's very important
that
you
really really have a true revelation
of what you're talking about
so a revelation
brings conviction
so you have to have a revelation on that
on that subject
so my type of
uh life coaching lot is in the area of
crisis
so i have my own story father dies at 10
that was difficult on my
my mother
raising
four children we have five but one had
already been married four children on
her own so that was my story right
but then i wanted to get a revelation on
crisis
coaching on how to bring somebody
through
their dilemma so you have your story but
then get educated in the area that you
want to help people in
do you still coach people beyond the
crisis are you the crisis management guy
well i started as a crisis guy
and then
now my last book was called come back
and beyond
but but i'm super good at the crisis
and the thing that i realized evan is
that people are going through something
always
and i i say that you're going through
recovery and discovery at all times so
recovery is you know healing from wounds
of our past
but so i was just like healing you of
the wounds in the past so now i'm also
the discovery coach too
so yes i deal with crisis but also deal
with the beyond now but that that's
something that i kind of grew into
are there any good programs or courses
or like if i want to be a life coach you
can't just go to university and become a
life coach there's some phenomenal ones
okay i mean i love john maxwell i think
that john maxwell's coach coaching
system is is one of the best so there's
probably about like five
amazing
uh coaching programs
i would have probably taken john's to
add to mine if i needed it but for me
i was fortunate because as you know i
work with entertainers
so what would happen is that if if i was
not educated
in an area
there was a there was a go-to
psychologist that's very well known that
taught at usc forever
and we i would go to her for the
some answers and then we created a
curriculum
and then i added two more psychologists
and one psychiatrist and we created a
550 page curriculum on coaching that's
phenomenal but without the revelation
the training won't help
well the training will help
but you got to know that you got to know
you got to know you got to you know it's
it's almost like
michael jordan
right he had a revelation
that
he was so good at being michael jordan
he you'd stick his tongue out you put
one defender two defenders three
defenders doesn't matter bam bam bam bam
same thing if somebody comes to me in a
crisis
i don't think i can be beat
i'm good i'm good at untying a knot
like when you were a kid did you ever
get a knot in your shoe yeah i still do
okay okay
so for some reason my mother was really
good at untied knots
i'm like a master at untie knots and is
that a combination of you just having to
untie so many knots in your own life
plus then learning the skills or it's
just a talent no i think it's i think
it's really more of
understanding the skill
the skill of
how to work through a crisis like how do
i work through this crisis
and so you know one of the ways you work
through a crisis number one is you have
to become awake
and then number two you got to take
inventory so i'm awake now i take
inventory oh crap what do i what did i
do to myself and then thirdly you got to
look for help
people stronger than yourself
okay
and then the the the fourth thing you
got to do is you got to cooperate with
your comeback
so just those principles alone
we've untied the knots of some of the
greatest minds in the world
do you then teach people how to use your
system
yes yes
so i would say
of
the 20 best life coaches in the world i
probably coach probably 12 to 14 of them
yeah that's my deal i like it and is it
a training system that anybody can sign
up for or is it is it public can they
find it well i think it's just they look
for me right and
at this stage of my life i'm like a
player coach you know i'm in my 50s
and i feel like i'm a player coach so i
only have so much time in the day
to do the one-on-one counseling that i
do
and so now i don't want to do like the
mass counseling but there are great
coaches that i coach
nowadays and really teach them this
system
from this over 500 pages
that we have created with the
psychologists and psychiatrists but you
know the the cool thing is it's changing
people's lives that's what it all comes
down to that's what you do that's what i
do
does the revelation come from a pain
the revelation can come from the pain
but the revelation is is an illumination
it's the oprah aha moment
okay
so the revelation
can come from
deep deep study and then you go bam i
get it but you do have to have empathy
and compassion to understand pain
so i've been through personal pain
but i also have compassion to understand
pain
so if i'm if somebody watching this yeah
they feel like life coaching's for them
they're
not 100 sure what the next step is or
how to get the best education what would
you say is my next three steps i need to
go off and start doing okay number one
you have to see what moves you i'm moved
by people hurting
so i remember i was running laps when i
was a kid
probably fifth grade
and there was a kid named freddy
who he was having an asthma attack in
the middle of these laps we were running
and me and this guy named don we used to
try to be
number one and two we'd switch off and
who was the best and i was beating don
this day
but i saw freddie have an asthma attack
and i stopped
winning to make sure freddie was okay
and and told the teacher so we can get
his inhaler so i was moved so number one
you got to be moved
number two find a mentor
so number one be moved what moves you
number two
get a mentor okay
and then number three
just open your lives to helping
someone
it's not usually like online coaching at
first
are you like get your own office space
just start being open to help give
somebody else a boost on the mentorship
side
how do you do that if somebody comes and
says hey tim will you meant to me i want
to be a life coach i'm sure there's tons
of people who would want that
opportunity and your time is
super limited how do you pick who you'd
want to mention okay on the mentor side
you just opened up the door because you
just came in my house
and we're doing these courses
to help them learn
so so that's good on you thanks for
doing this does that make sense yeah
yeah no that's what you're doing yeah
yeah so we're we're not charging them
right now
so
so they are being mentored
by somebody who's a master at what i do
so there's their answer right there
and they're following you
[Laughter]
so there's books and podcasts and you've
done lots of other videos and interviews
yes but then the actual
hey tim i'm dealing with this client i
don't know what to do i don't know how
to help them yeah they're struggling
there's good manuals out there yeah on
on coaching
how to coach
okay there's a great podcast that that
you know some of us have been on and
we're sharing secrets
and and then you know
i'm a pretty open guy so if they can
find me i always try to like
pay it forward and what do you need to
see from a mentee because i think most
mentees yeah here's the thing i think
mentors love giving back yeah i do it's
the greatest it's the greatest thing of
all time but you hate wasting your time
yeah and so so many mentees never follow
through that
it's hard to make that i'm not i'm
looking for heart yeah i'm looking for
heart like if somebody cares about
people
if they're helping somebody like in the
addiction space like i help a lot of
people in the addiction space
and so if i see somebody that is trying
to help somebody
man i'm there i want to help you because
you may help stop a young man from
overdosing on heroin
so it's worth my time and would you say
it's better to have somebody come in and
say hey tim will you be my mentor or hey
tim i'm struggling with this one
question
i think it's both okay i think it's both
i think you know as you just said
time
is a factor for you and me
right and so
sometimes it's like hey take a drive
with me to starbucks while we talk
sometimes it's you know let's do a skype
meeting or zoom meeting or sometimes
it's like hey read this book that book
helped me or watched that podcast that
podcast helped me got it
and then back to just education and
getting enough qualifications and
feeling like you're ready what about the
people who feel like they're never ready
that they'll look at you and say well
i'm not tim's story level yeah i can't
do that so you you share
from the position that you are
presently
like there's some really good coaches
that are like 20 years of age
they're not like 42 but they're 20. so
share from where you are presently but
realize be careful man you got people's
lives in your hands
so i i literally keep my phone on 24
hours
a day because you know i've had i've had
13 people die on me
in the last year
they died
wow so it's no joke to me yeah yeah they
died so i mean that's very sober right
but this is all real stuff
so it's not like oh man i'm a coach i'm
out there making money
no people are dying
so we've saved a lot of lives and we
lost lives so it's serious stuff
how do you deal with the weight of that
of like this is imagine life and death
the weight of like somebody passing is
is heavy stuff
it really is i mean like um there's a
group i work with called melrose
recovery
and um
you know you see a young guy a young
woman come in
and
they're just not themselves
and maybe they're there two three weeks
and it looks like they're going to make
it they're like tim i'm going to make it
oh my god your stuff is working
and then you know sometimes these people
will leave
and you hear four months later that they
od'd in a hotel
room it's it's it's it's really really
really tough stuff it's tough stuff
but to me
it it makes me want to get better
better at understanding better at giving
answers right you know you can feel the
burden of that like i totally do how do
you not feel
i'm their life coach they died it's my
fault how do you get over that well i i
i don't i don't think that there is
a a way to like dust it off like it was
a bad a bad game like if you're an
athlete i'm feeling the weight just now
man i carry it yeah i carry it i carry
it i i just went to a funeral today you
know
so um this is all real to me
but i think that that's why even if i'm
dealing with a famous actor
that they may not be
in a crisis like they're going to die
but i do believe that the pain
that i carry
from other people
makes me good at all levels
man it's so important you
got to carry the pain
i like it
since this video is about getting
educated
what last tip would you have for people
who want to be a life coach that you
feel they're missing in their education
path
i think look for mentors as you brought
up earlier
of people that are that are good coaches
i think renee brown is phenomenal she as
as a writer
of uh you know daring bravely and and
getting through some of the pain of your
past uh my good friend she's my friend
too also yon lavanzant
and and what she's done about getting
through pain
uh
my stuff my book utmost living don't get
stuck in almost life my book come back
and beyond i think it's you know
i think that's a group of people that
actually really care
so you're gonna you're gonna feel that
from our writings and also from what we
say in interviews this is part two today
we're talking about how to be original
tim what do you got for us number one
thanks for doing this it's it's really
helping people right i hope so man
that's the goal
so there's a saying that says
uh you're born an original don't die a
copy
but nobody knows who came up with it
does that make sense yeah yeah yeah
so to to be original is unique one of a
kind
so i think that even in coaching
we can learn from other coaches from the
past because coaching's been around a
long time
but i also think that you need to be
original
and a lot of that is based on what your
life story is okay
so
how who have you learned from in the
past that impacted you the most just as
a starting point okay so
my life story is you know lower income
struggling seven people in a two-bedroom
apartment
so
i
really
tend to lean towards the struggler okay
so this is a funny thing someone gave me
a book about the life of mother teresa
okay
so when i was in high school junior in
high school i started to read about
mother teresa i read one book then read
another book and then i started studying
different articles about mother teresa
on how she had a heart for the orphans
and so
i learned how she was mentoring orphans
so really my
original mentor how cool is this is
mother teresa that's wild
that's cool yeah she loved the underdog
okay so after you met did you meet her i
never met her no i never met her but you
know i studied where her where her house
uh was
how she how she learned
who her her mentors were the sacrifice
that she made
and um so i learned
from her successes and challenges and
you've heard this before
success leaves clues
and so i saw that she was was caring she
was compassionate but she also
really learned how to take people
and and put them into a program so they
can get out of their situation
so
amazing if mother teresa that's such a
wild
uh
yeah as a mentor as a life coach kid for
a kid from compton i love it it's great
so so mother teresa is your mentor yes
you're gonna learn from her from the
books and documentaries and things that
have been written about her because she
didn't have a youtube channel to watch
your videos exactly
now how do you take what she did and say
okay i'm gonna apply that to life
coaching and be an original okay so so
here's what we got
so
the original site of mother teresa
is that she was a a school teacher
and she was going into to teach one day
and you know she was a nun
and she noticed that the same orphans
were outside the school day after day
and she started thinking to herself i
need to do something about these orphans
so she started to to educate the orphans
just on the streets
and then she said i got to take this
even deeper and she she found a place
for just a few orphans to actually live
well more and more orphans started
finding out about it
and so now they begin to gather
so she was educating them housing them
educating them housing them it's
powerful right
so then she came to her superior
and said i think that this is my calling
so that was her original thing
and that was mother teresa being
original so
her compassion was real her love was
real
and then the fact that she knew i had to
educate him and i needed to feed them
so with tim's story being an original in
what i do
i i took it from my mother theresa i
need to educate people
and i need to feed them not not food i
need to feed them
the right
information so they could rise up
so very very similar compassion and food
and i'm feeding you material to help you
rise up that's what i do i love it man
that's wild i got to process that
so so how do you get for people watching
they want to be a life coach you're
trying to figure out how can they be
original what would you recommend as a
starting point a process i think it's
very important to look at your at your
past like what were your interests when
you when you were little
and so
what my interest when i when i was
little was you know i love sports
but i also really always had compassion
for people
so early on in my life coaching i used a
lot of
sports metaphors okay so i'm known for
this i could be like telling a a
powerful beverly hills woman she'll go
like so what do i do the fool left me
after 20 years i go
you got to just hit singles and she goes
what's that have to do with anything i
go yeah because most people they try to
hit home runs
but just hit a single
hit another single hit another single
hit another single and you'll build your
confidence so it's really a crack up
that sports metaphors
even the beverly hills women actually
work
do you know where the outer left field
comes from
uh
i do not and but i love to study all
those things whenever there's a saying
that i don't understand
i i like to to find that out so it's
probably like out of from out of nowhere
like it wasn't expected right but why
why it's a baseball analogy i'm assuming
because it's left field yes but why that
yeah i think it could have been out of
right field but the person just thought
of left field so it just means you just
have to look it up it means from out of
nowhere yeah
yeah i just was curious as to why yeah i
get the singles in the home but isn't
that wild so so me being an original was
i took the fact
that i was i was born lower income
and then so i have compassion for people
uh i was in a cramped environment so i
don't want to be cramped and i don't
want you to be cramped and then i love
sports
so i started using those metaphors so to
to be an original in your coaching
because that's what we're teaching
um
lean on your past
and if you love deep sea fishing use
those as some metaphors
uh some of these guys that have been
captains and in uh of ships they use
that right or uh take a lewis house he
was a professional football player he
uses a lot of those things so whatever
your past is
take from your past and use it in your
coaching
that requires courage
yes to being original it does to say i'm
gonna be a life coach based off of
mother teresa's philosophy of feeding
people right is a wild concept that to
lean in on it and to succeed with it
requires courage yes so it depends on
how good you want to be at being a coach
because if you just mimic somebody
you're going to be like a karaoke coach
you got a pound right there i was
thinking alphys impersonator but that
was good man karaoke coach there's too
many karaoke coaches out there
does that make sense i'm a hundred
percent look they're just like reading
it's it's not even a sports analogy it's
it's it's
coaching yeah i'm not a karaoke coach
i love it
says because i'm i'm bringing my stuff
i'm bringing the fact that man i i have
been through pain so i just met with
probably one of the most famous men in
the whole world
and so i came in
and he goes you don't have any notes on
you like he thought i was going to walk
in
seriously he's one of the most famous
man in the world
i i didn't come in with a big binder i
came in with me
i just started dropping bombs on the guy
just saw his life just start changing
like in 30 minutes
why because
i'm original
i'm dropping my life story i'm dropping
my education i'm dropping what i learned
it's like jay-z
he's not nervous to get up there and
rhyme because he's not he's not a
karaoke jay-z he is jay-z
joker jay i don't
no i love that this is good right but it
still requires confidence like courage
to go and do
the thing and am i good enough that my
story will move people yes so practice
so so so practice like
okay
when you're going into a convenience
store someone's gonna be there begging
okay
coach them
does that make sense
you have friends
coach them
see what's hit see what's missed see
what's working see what's not working
yeah like i'm coaching people
every day if you went with me to the
airport
okay i gotta go somewhere on wednesday
you will see from the minute i walk
through lax
to the time i get on the plane someone's
gonna say hey tim story
right from the beginning the guys that
handle bags yo what's up tim tim hey
just a second i got the situation with
my girlfriend boom boom boom boom boom
because i've been rolling through there
for 25 years so they know what i do they
know who i am they they're always asking
me hey tim story i cannot go to a
restroom on any airplane i mean any
airplane if i get up and walk to the
back somebody grabs me right true story
hey tim story
so you can coach everywhere practice but
you're saying even if they don't know
you you do the outreach you go and find
somebody who might need help yeah
exactly so okay so i'm known as a coach
so if you're not known as a coach
look for the
need
success is finding the need
and filling it
so just be open
okay
pay attention
realize it's hurting people everywhere
and then share your story
and and if it's life coach
i don't think most people love their
life yeah so everybody's in need
everybody's everywhere every everybody's
going through something
at some point in their life here's
another way of looking at it everybody's
coping right now
okay so when you go to get gas
if you decide to go in
the store to maybe get water or
something else that person the reason
they're acting grouchy could be they're
coping with something
so maybe you just say some kind words
so
i'm telling you everywhere
around here where i live i'm coaching
probably like 33 people
in this whole area that work at places
not joking
if you went with me today to some of
these places even at starbucks
probably three of their employees are
gonna say hey tim's story and ask me a
question
do you think you need to start off as a
karaoke coach and then develop your
style or do you go original from the
start no no no you do have to start off
as a karaoke coach you you you have to
mimic
somebody to start
so you could see coaches that you did
you look to uh brene brown ian levanzan
tim story you gotta you gotta find
coaches that you look to
and then the the better you get
your own style will begin to emerge just
like in basketball
like you know
study study michael
jordan study study larry bird how he
dribbles okay so it's okay to it's okay
to be a karaoke coach at first but don't
be a karaoke coach like seven years in
got it the original that's what we're
talking about so you're putting on the
tim story hat you're seeing how it fits
trying it on
but at some point it's gonna feel just a
little bit uncomfortable in some spots
because it's tim's story and not you
yeah i mean they're spitting my rhymes
everywhere i go
like everywhere i go someone's saying
sometimes you got to get left before you
get right that's tim's story
right
don't get stuck in almost life that's
tim's story but what what a what a
compliment
that now they are karaoke in my songs
right
right and so how do i find that original
original piece when i'm trying on your
hat the more you the more you do it
just like what you do okay you're really
good at what you do
so the more you do it
it just starts coming out then it's just
like it's just you and they have to
trust it
test it have the courage to trust it
today we're talking about how to
understand your audience
tim what do you got for us
well you know
every audience is different
so like as a speaker because you speak
as well
whenever i speak i got to know what is
the culture
and what is the climate so let's say if
i'm speaking in stockholm sweden that's
going to be different if i speak
in rome italy so it's a different
culture right
then the climate is also going to be
different so if like you speak first
and you like so hype the crowd up
because you're so doggone good
so the climate i got to understand that
too
so that's going to really help me
navigate what my approach is going to be
it's the same thing in coaching okay
so
if somebody is going through a crisis
let's say they're going through a
divorce
i gotta understand the climate
and the culture
of what that person is going through so
my tone has to be different
what i'm expecting from that client is
going to be different
if it's a person that wants to be
coached and they're saying hey
listen the la dodgers wants me and so
does the cincinnati reds look at tim
this is amazing different climate
different culture you definitely have to
understand
who you're coaching and what they're
going through
how much do you adapt your style to them
versus saying here's my niche come to me
if you're dealing with this i totally
have to adjust my style okay and that's
where people really mess up i think some
people are just not good at this
is that they try to bring
like a system
that's worked on
person a b and c
to somebody that's going through a
terrible terrible crisis like for
instance
i got called to a hospital
because someone had been in a very very
serious accident
as soon as i walked in to the hospital i
couldn't believe it that i asked one of
my friends to count there were 33 family
members that were hovering around
because they thought this man could die
and they were waiting for tim story to
show up to bring hope
so i didn't come up
and act like tim's story the
motivational speaker
i came in super quiet
i sat down with everybody
i talked to people one on one
i went and saw the person that had been
in this accident thank goodness he came
out of it he was in a coma okay
so the person that brought me in said i
think my family needs to be rallied
they're down they need to be rallied
that's the last thing they needed they
needed somebody just to care about them
so understanding that type of situation
is how i came in
and spoke to them and how do you deal
with that when when a client asks you to
do one thing but you know
you should be doing the exact opposite
yeah you become good at it
okay so
so i was a really good pitcher when i
was a kid baseball pitcher okay okay
so
if my catcher
so simple simple signs when you're 12.
one is a fastball two is a curve three
is a drop because i had a wicked drop
so if he went like this one fastball i'm
like i wave him off
i'm not throwing a fastball that dude
he's gonna hit it over the over the
fence i'm gonna throw my wicked drop
so i'd wave him off
so if i go into a accounting situation
even with a celebrity the manager may
say okay this is what he needs man right
he totally needs you to and i go oh
interesting
i'll take that into consideration but
i'm really waving them off
right
yeah so it's experience
so based on my experience
of understanding the climate and the
culture of what that person's going
through
i need to adjust
the way i'm coaching that person here's
another thing
some people
the crisis they're in they're not
getting out
in one tim story session
or they're not getting out and one ianna
van zandt changed my life on own network
session right are you with me yeah it's
gonna take them three months
six months nine months a year
i think that's why people keep coming
back to me because i'll tell people the
truth i'll say you know what
man dude
you've been at this for a long time it's
gonna probably take you about 12 months
you're like no
i don't want to hear that i go it's the
truth
so it's a step-by-step
process so i get into the realities with
people
and understand what they got themselves
into so if they if they make bad choices
to get in that dilemma it's going to
take better choices to get them out
what are some of the signs that you're
paying attention to i'm sure even as you
just walk in the room
you're already scanning the room you're
looking at the people or looking at your
clients seeing their body language like
what are the some of the signs that
you're paying attention to that you're
saying okay i need to go in okay so
let's let's get in specific so
understand your audience okay
someone
is
55 years of age
worked for the same company since he was
22.
they fire him
okay
so how do you think he feels devastated
so what tone should i come at you tell
me what tone should i have towards this
guy empathetic understanding
low key i'm bringing it down right
okay so how does that feel
like man i can't believe they did that
so what are your thoughts right now i
want to get even
i i i i i want to get on yelp i i i i i
want to tell people right
i know secrets about the boss maybe
that's not what we should do you get my
void right okay so somebody loses their
job
in their 50s that's one thing okay
if somebody is about to get married in a
week
and now they're having second thoughts
similar tone
okay
why are you having second thoughts
because he's a raging fool
[Laughter]
how do you know that
because of boom boom boom boom yeah okay
all right maybe we should reconsider
this even though you've already invited
800 people
yeah so it depends on the situation i i
love the voice already did you go into
like this oh i go though oh it's great
that's a great voice yeah these other
guys mess it up yeah see
these other guys messing all up by by
coming in
with like this big life coach tone
when a person's in in crisis
right but you gotta remember i also deal
with people that are like living like
way up here
so it's like oh my gosh you're never
gonna believe it i'm up for academy
award
so i don't know if i should invite my
ex-wife or i don't know if i should
invite my mother-in-law i'd have to fly
her in from sweden so that's a whole
different tone like hey yeah maybe hey
that's interesting let's look at that
whole different tone do you want to
match them yeah
you got to match where the person's at
it match where they're at how much how
much of the how much pre-research are
you doing on people versus just going in
and sensing the vibe when you walk in
okay so important because here's the
deal now
is that it used to be that a lot of
coaching was one-on-one
so it's me and you at a restaurant
it's me and you at starbucks it's me and
you on the golf course
now it's me and you on zoom it's me and
you on skype right it's me and you and
whatsapp
right
so i can't always feel it out
so i'll take my time like the other day
i had a client
and i could see that he was a little
uptight more than he usually is
and so i just started pushing certain
buttons to see where his mood was
and then the guy started getting all
emotional and he's not the emotional
type he literally started crying
and i was glad that i pushed those
buttons
and went down to that quiet
mode now i couldn't touch him but i was
touching him through my tone and through
my words
and how important is touch for you in
the coaching process um i think i think
touch is important not just physical
touch
but it's more of an emotional touch
see because like when i go into prisons
sometimes you can't touch anybody
there's a glass
so but i'm still touching them through
my tongue
and so that's powerful stuff
powerful
how do you take that message of a
one-on-one to then translate it to 100
people might be watching you in prison
well i think that in that case again it
is tone
so let's say that
if i'm speaking to a group of prisoners
that i know they're going to get out
within a year
i'm teaching maybe on hope
if i'm teaching to a group of prisoners
that are in there
ten years to life
i'm teaching at a different tone
i'm teaching on prosper where you're
planted
that even though you're in the midst of
this sometimes you got to get left
before you get right
you use this left experience as a
library and sanctuary to somebody that i
know it's getting on
12 months i'm teaching them about hope
and preparing them
to get out so you have to know
your audience guys you got to know your
audience and so you got to understand
this also
that i make i may coach
seven people in one day
so i make i may coach a guy that's worth
a billion dollars
and then i may coach a young 22 year old
who's struggling with addiction
so i better really watch my tone right
between the 20 billion dollar guy and
the kid who's struggling with addiction
so you gotta you gotta shift it up so
i'm constantly watch
turning the page
turning the page
see so even
you you and your crew that's here
i was checking out your tone on purpose
okay
like i was somewhere and i came back
early on purpose i wanted to know your
tone the minute you walked in my house
so what did you get from my tone how
cool you are okay
you're just
you're an amazing man i just felt
brilliance all over you
i used to use that as a case study
testimonial right there tim's story
edge's high roll but what so but how
would so in understanding me yeah
what do you then shift in in either the
stories you tell
or your demeanor or like how are you
changing i shifted you without you even
knowing i shifted you you shifted me i
did today i mean i felt that too but but
it's interesting because at the
beginning i asked you you said well you
need to shift to your
to the person that you're dealing with
yes so you want to understand me get
into my world and then you're trying to
bring me
no i don't want you in mind okay
i want you to get into a state
that is best for you to handle the
situation okay okay so so in in the in
the case of today you guys have been on
the road you're doing this amazing tour
right right so now you're like boom boom
boom one place to another so now you see
tim sorry hi tim story you're not grant
cardone hi tim
you're you're not president obama sure
it's me hi it's tim's story so i took my
time and then you started to feel
my essence and who i am okay right yeah
so then you started to like get on the
same wavelength as me so now we can chop
it up and do a better job
that's very oprah
i like it that's why oprah is the best
at what she does
she takes people into her place
and then how do you do that in such a
short amount of time what are you
looking for what signs what techniques
um listen
dealing with you today is going to be
different than dealing with you tomorrow
okay it all depends on how you woke up
what kind of food you ate
how you how you slept right
so if you're in a different mood
tomorrow i'll handle that mood too
i'm just i'm just i'm i'm looking for
body language
spoken words
movement erratic behavior
yeah
people get blown away
most managers say nobody has ever been
able to talk to my client like this
like i can name
10 of the biggest
entertainers in the world that their
managers say
nobody
can talk to that guy or that lady that
way
so i i pay attention and they respect
you for it yeah because you're telling
them truth no i'm
bringing them in today is episode four
we're talking about how to be a good
listener
i'm excited for this one yeah if you're
gonna be a coach
i think some people think coaching
is verbal that you're just telling
people what to do
like oh you're in this crisis here's the
seven things you must do right
really
if you're a great coach you're a great
listener
and so let's let's talk baseball just
for a second i love it tommy lasorda
what used to be the coach of the dodgers
okay
so he was great verbally but people
don't realize that he was also great if
if it if a player was struggling he'd go
on the bench and sit next to him put his
arm on him and just listen
like how you feeling today how's your
family like during the game
let's take basketball i phil jackson he
was very zen
he was a great listener
anywhere from michael jordan all the way
to a dennis rodman so i think my
strength in coaching
i'm a phenomenal listener not just good
i'm phenomenal i love it so so break
that down how do we become a phenomenal
listener okay so first you gotta have
three sisters and a mother
okay so here's the deal two okay well
you gotta have three okay
so i'm the youngest child okay
so
all three sisters older than me
okay raised by my mother because my
father passes when i'm 10.
so
my older sisters were always telling
stories
i'm the youngest i got to listen to the
stories
i'm hearing about what they're doing at
school i'm hearing about a guy they have
a crush on so i just learned to be this
good listener my mother has no husband
my brother is older than me he's out
doing things so i become
the listener to all the words that my
mother has and my sisters have i became
a very good listener so i would say
listening
is one of the most powerful things i
have in my arsenal
everybody says that
so i can i could be coaching somebody
who's you know super well known or not
as well known and they'll say this is
wild
i feel like you really listen to me be a
good listener i love that you say wild
because that's been our word for the
tour yes everything is wild so it's
great that wild is good i love it yes
so i'm a good listener and so
here's here's what's important
is it i think in in listening
too many people are thinking about what
they're going to say next
so let's say if they're a life coach
okay
our life advisor so they have their
manual and they're like okay
what's your two-year goal what's your
four-year goal if you knew you couldn't
fail what would you want to do
hey
pay attention to what they just said
because in their last answer is
probably the goal you're looking for so
let's say if i'm live coaching somebody
i'll say
when you're a child what did you think
about becoming
and they may say
uh i didn't have a clue
i don't go question number two
i'll say
what do you mean you didn't have a clue
like you you never thought of it or
nobody gave you ideas about it or you
never saw something that moved you
i may stick with that answer i don't
never had a clue for 30 minutes and not
go to question number two that's being a
good listener
and how do you know that that's guiding
you down the right path instead of just
meandering around and never getting to
the thing that you want to solve well i
think i think that what happens it
depends on whatever the subject is okay
so let's let's just work on you just for
a second just for fun yeah yeah let's do
it okay all right so um
when you were
right out of college okay what did you
think about becoming
entrepreneur i was running my business
not having success doing it turned down
big jobs to be an entrepreneur and make
300 bucks a month and own 30 of a
company and wanted to succeed okay why
did you turn down big
jobs
fear of regret
i didn't want to miss out on
not knowing if that company would work
or not how did that feel to turn down
those jobs
and then in hindsight find out that oh
my gosh
maybe i turned down a really good
opportunity that could have put me in a
better position
i had a i had something to happen a year
before that made me have the strength
and courage to go off and do it because
i didn't want to live my entire life not
knowing i could deal with the failure
and i could deal with it not working out
and knowing that i could get another job
yeah and it'd be the same job but i can
get another job this whole company thing
i didn't know if i'd have the chance
again so i had to do it okay so you want
me to tell you what i heard yeah okay
yeah yeah of course so number one
is you had opportunities
and you turned them down
not just regular regular means standard
normal
right you turn down big
which is larger than normal right so did
you see how i i took the word big
and then i used big
jobs
then i said how does it feel
how did that feel to turn down a big job
because the big job
could have
left you in a big mess because you
turned down the big job right
and then we talked about that and then
you talked about your resilience
and where that came from
and
i let you explain that so i got like
three great points out of you in just
about two and a half minutes so how
would you then use that
to coach me on something i'm going
through right now okay so then i would
say then now
are there some big opportunities that
are coming your way now
that seems similar to what you went
through
before and you may say oh man this is
weird that you're saying this because
there are some big things right okay so
now
the first time you turn down the big
but maybe we don't turn it down this
time
so we got to really figure out
what this opportunity is
because just because it's dressed in big
this may be the big one we want to take
okay
see
so
i'm taking your big opportunity
and i'm going from there
then i'm saying the thing i like about
you is is is the fact that you're
resilient
and then i would say to you where did
you learn that resiliency you think it's
innate did it come from your family did
it come to going through from uh going
through hardships so where did you get
that resilience from
parents
okay yeah my mom immigrant hard-working
uh super ambitious successful woman in a
time when it was not accepted or common
okay so now by being a good listener i
got big opportunity you're resilient
and it's innate
so which says to me going forward if i
start coaching you now
this year and i coach you for 20 years
whenever i see you i'm going to think to
myself
that guy somehow someway somehow some
way he knows how to get through things
because it's in him it's innate
and then and then how would you find
the block
the block is probably going to be found
in what you say
about the situation okay okay so so
whatever you're going through
if you verbalize what you're going
through i'm still going to remember
this guy is confident enough to pass up
big stuff
this guy is resilient
this man learned things from his mother
and it's now innate it's instilled it's
a revelation
give him any situation he's going to
find a way around it so like if you have
a mountain now i'm coaching you yeah
yeah it's great if you have a mountain
in your life
if you don't go through it you'll go
around it yep
if you don't go through it or around it
your butt's going over it pound yeah bam
life coaching for free right here
and so if i'm if i'm stuck in a
situation is it reminding me of that of
that like this is who i am and you're
gonna bring that back out of me because
i've forgotten if you're stuck in a
situation we gotta go back
to how you got unstuck last time okay so
i gotta use a biblical reference if you
don't mind great go for it doctorate in
world religion so there's a little guy
in the bible named david
so he's going to fight goliath he goes
i killed a lion
i killed a bear
i think i could take down goliath
so in coaching you i'm gonna go back to
your lion your bear
to build your confidence that you could
take down goliath
see the thing i like about you
is in in our dialogue there are some
things that you've gone through that are
like little mini crisis that have come
up
in the last month right sure yeah you
killed a lion
you killed a bear
you're going to take that down too
because you told me
you go it's no big deal i'm still alive
you killed a lion you killed a bear you
could take that down so by being a good
listener
i listened that you killed a lion you
killed the bear you could take down
goliath if someone's a bad coach
they didn't kill they didn't hear the
lion and the bear story
isn't that brilliant i like it
i like it um i'm just thinking is is
part of the reason why we need life
coaches so much because
people don't have anybody in their life
who actually listens to them you need
the right life coach you just don't need
a life coach you need
because if if you're if you're a golfer
like i'm playing golf tomorrow
if you're a golfer and you have the
wrong swing coach
it'll jack you up
you need the right freaking mentors
no man it's not like
here you hear you i need a life coach no
man you got to find the right coach
that understands your swing
that understands your flow that
understands your rhythm
and they care enough about you
to help you find the obvious in your
life now because we're talking about
listening
when i'm coaching somebody
i'm looking for
the obvious
i'm not always looking for
i'm gonna tell this person what to do
next
i'm looking for the obvious i'm i'm i'm
looking for
what you say
what you've missed
what you've
misplaced what you
forgot to do
i'm looking for the obvious
so after talking to someone probably for
about 10 minutes i'll find their obvious
and if somebody wants to acquire that
skill to find the obvious in 10 minutes
or less tim's story style
be a good listener here's a good way to
to to practice yeah okay
so to some of my clients
i have them wear rubber band okay
and i say to them because i like coach a
lot of powerful men i got i got kind of
one on here so okay i forgot this
okay yeah all right so so some of my
some of my powerful men
they bring their job home okay and their
wives complain that they're not
listening
so i say to them
okay now
i want you to wear this rubber band
for like two weeks
and when your wife starts talking
and you to
cut her off okay leave the room
i want you to
flick the band
it reminds you to just shh
and listen
these guys are coming back with his
reports and going my wife is saying what
happened to you
[Laughter]
you sat there and listened to me talk
about curtains like you really loved it
it's a great it's a great it's a great
tool boom you should sell tim's story
rubber bands boom am i brandon we'll do
it together i love it
boom look you're not listening watch
boom
see boom don't you like that it's
meditative yes listen
yeah being present be present listen i'm
a good listener today episode 5 we're
talking about having the right motives i
know this one is personal to tim
what do you got man it's real personal
why did you ask me that question that's
how personal it is
okay
you gotta have the right motives because
here's the deal
so if you're life coaching someone
so they feel like they have a need
like
what's my career path right
what should i do i just got divorced
how can i handle being single how can i
handle being married
uh i aspire to be this person
so you have to have the right motives
have compassion
empathy really care about these
individuals to give them the proper
answers what do you think what do you
think people's motives are coming in
okay
i think a lot of people's motives are
good okay okay like i know a lot of
social workers they don't get paid that
much money
and they have good motives i know a lot
of psychiatrists that do not get paid
that much money they have good motives
psychologists okay
don't get paid that much money
but i know a lot of people in this space
of life coaching now because they've
seen the money that some people make
their motives
are
how many big clients they can get
how they can
sell and upsell people to get
enormous amounts of money and they're
not thinking about the client the person
they're thinking about theirs own
personal success and that irritates me
so what if uh somebody comes in and says
oh that person's my next suit that
person's my next car right if i close
that person i can get that car
put it up on instagram
then you're gonna irritate me
yeah that's gonna irritate me you know
why because again
okay
so
if if if a guy's in a crisis
okay let's take a guy that uh
plays major league baseball
so his
agent calls for tim's story
the guy used to hit like about 300
something and then he went down into the
200s okay these are true stories because
i do a lot of athletes
so now he's all vulnerable he's like
he's heard what i've done with other
athletes so he's all vulnerable okay
so he says to me okay so what do i do so
i got this guy
to watch film of when he was hitting
over 300
and just watch himself with his swing
just bam bam bam bam bam bam i'm telling
you in two weeks his problem got solved
he started getting confidence by just
watching the old film right
what if i didn't care about the guy but
before i had him watch film i want to
know about his mother
his father
his two kids right i'm joking with him
i'm teasing with them because i care
about the person now this is super super
common with me
where someone will say
i'm in a major crisis i live in another
country i am flying myself
to meet with you
i will pay you 20 000 for the day
30 000 for the day
money's not option
i'll say okay
watch how common this is i'll sit down
with them for lunch
i'm solving their problem they go to pay
and i go
don't want it keep it they'll go what i
got money i go i don't want it
dude you just paid all that money to fly
here
and to stay in a hotel you trusted me
enough i don't want your money
this happens all the time
i would say out of the 10 people that i
coach
only about six of them pay
i won't take the money
why are you staring at me
i'm processing it
the truth
you read what you sow
i'm processing it because i'm
and we're going way off topic but i love
it
i'm facing that situation right now yes
with what i do on youtube in that
there's a lot of people who are
massively successful yes offline yeah
and want to build a youtube brand and
i'm helping them
for free yeah just taking the knowledge
out of my head and helping them get
their message out because they want to
build legacy and they see youtube as a
way to spread their message and build
legacy people worth
tons and tons and tons of money yes way
more than me yeah and i'm just there
helping them
it's all coming back to you
you reap what you sow
okay so those other guys that are all
into their own self when when when
smokey robinson got his
uh
lifetime achievement award for naacp did
he call them no he called me
are you with me
all these big plays i'm doing movies
that i'm doing all these things at the
highest level
are they calling them no they're calling
me it's not by accident
is is oprah winfrey hanging out with
them no is she hanging out with me yeah
thank you very much
you reap what you sow
you reap what you sow
i i do it because my motives
i love people yeah so if that guy just
flew all the way from london to talk to
tim storey
a guy that used to be you know from a
lower income family and now i really
know what i'm talking about
dude i'm not taking your 20 000
stack
go on your way
so when do you start to charge or how do
you start the charge well the reason the
reason i charge
the main reason i charge because i have
many ways that i make money i own a lot
of companies
is because i want people to respect my
time and value my time
because sometimes when i don't charge
somebody i'll say to them okay well
they'll make the appointment with my one
of my assistants and they'll say okay
i'll get on zoom
at nine in the morning but i'm not
charging them i'm there at zoom at nine
nine ten they're not there 9 20 they're
not there 9 30 starts to take me off
so i notice that people appreciate what
they pay for for someone who wants to
make life coaching their business and
they may not make money from
all the other investors
like okay so i need to i need to charge
when when do you do it how do you figure
that process out again charge but let
your motives be right
let it not be about
money
let it be about helping people
and what's going to happen
is the money is going to follow
you
being helpful to people
like so many of the things that happened
to me
like holy shmoley guacamole people try
to give me everything they try to give
me horses
boats sailboats
i'm not even joking i think you need a
horse in here this be great yeah they
tried giving me everything
it's not by accident you reap
what you sow but for those that are
starting in coaching charge but make
your prices reasonable
if you're the fir your first year in
coaching
you know come on be reasonable second
year be reasonable i've been coaching
people for almost 30 years
so my prices are higher than most but
they're not
even near what some of my peers charge
just because i care
so taking it personal for me
if you needed if you wanted to do
youtube yeah i would just help you yes
and i would i would spend a lot of time
and care and effort looking at your
channel and looking at your analytics
and coming with suggestions and i would
treat it like it was my own
yes because i want you to win i want
your message to get even these videos i
want your message to get out there and
that's why we're sitting here today
right because
before we did this segment i said
something to you okay i'm older than you
okay i'm in my 50s and i said to you hey
i like you if you need something i got
your back
i ain't playing
like
i can i could do things does that make
sense yeah i don't say that to everybody
i like your vibe
i like your family's vibe i like your
staff's vibe
so
you reap what you sow you didn't ask me
i said it during the break
good stuff right it's good stuff it's
just figuring out the balance come on
when you got oprah yeah and oprah will
probably watch this
and and i'm just chilling with and she
goes tell me what you want
that's good right yes okay
i love this guy
i don't even know what we're talking
about anymore have the right motives
have my motives you know why it's gonna
come back to you man
it's gonna come back to you do you
believe people are good fundamentally i
think people are good but they put bad
stuff in them
i think they came out of their mother's
womb pretty good but so like if i have
if i have a cup
and it's empty
depending on what i pour in it it's
whether i should drink it or not
so you got to really watch
what you watch with your eye gate and
what you hear with your ear gate
so i'm constantly monitoring what i
watch and what i hear
so i keep my motives pure
it's all about character and if you if
you if you suck in a certain area get
better i'm not talking about being
angelic i'm just saying get better have
motives
have the right motives you have the
right motives
the world will come looking for you
i don't advertise
over and over and over we let people
know we have services
but man i've stayed busy all these years
because people look for us
i love it man
this is episode six on how to have the
right mindset
what do you got man okay when you think
mindset what do you think
smart talking to a smart man well you
put me on the spot it's the best i love
it i think uh
i think
making sure that you're
you're
motivated every day making sure that
you're coming from service every day yes
making sure that you're
feeling bold
every day because you're showing up
every day okay good
all right so so if you're coaching me
okay i need you to have that to come to
me okay because here's what here's what
i say
if
you have nothing to give
how are you going to help me
so a lot of people like they say i want
to give i want to i want to help i want
to i want to help the hurting okay i'm
glad
those are your motives like we talked
about earlier
but you have to have
the right mindset
you have to be filled
with the right things you have to be
clear you have to have clarity you have
to have
knowledge you have to have compassion so
the mindset is so so so important in
coaching
you cannot coach well
with an empty head
you've got to come filled you know that
before i coach people in the morning
i cuz because of my spiritual background
i do devotions
okay
i pray
and i go to the gym
so by the time i coach somebody early in
the morning
i'm like
i'm prepared bam to go at it i don't
just like roll out of bed and then try
to help somebody through the dilemma
gotta have the right mindset
how do you avoid
so a lot of people who do prayer
sometimes they come out of the prayer
and it's and it's meaningful and they're
moved and yeah they felt the connection
and they're set to go and other days
they just kind of went through the
motions read the prayer
asked for something but then they don't
have the same emotional connection after
how do you make sure that you come out
of that prayer every single day feeling
on fire okay so we're talking we're
talking about how to strengthen your
mindset
because prayer and meditation
will strengthen your mindset
okay
and the mindset
will change your mood set i guarantee
you the mindset will change your mood
set
so here's how i look at prayer
meditation
it is
like plowing the ground and planting the
seed
you plow the ground you plant the seed
you don't just get the harvest the same
every day so some days you'll meditate
and you'll pray it doesn't feel the same
but you still have been plowing and then
planting seed
but the seed that you planted
may affect you in 30 minutes
but it may affect you in two days three
days four days five days so a lot of my
prayer meditation and my devotional time
is not just for the present but it's for
my future
see that's very very powerful
so i'm today's decisions are tomorrow's
realities this is the way i say it so
today's decisions are tomorrow's reality
so so if i pray today
and i study today
i may feel it today or i might fill in
three days but i'm going to feel the
change
so today's decisions are tomorrow's
realities what's what's the mindset that
you want to have on a daily basis what
activities would you use i want to have
a mindset of
clarity
i want to go into a coaching session
because we're talking about being a life
coach right
i want to i want to go into that
coaching session with clarity
and because
the coach
may be going through their own dilemma
so i got to make sure
that i'm handling
my emotions
and the challenge of my mindset
so i can now hear what's going on here
because like somebody may say
i may say hey how are you doing they say
uh
not so well a great friend of mine
passed away
if you're not paying attention you may
say
oh that's great so let's talk about what
we talked about last time right
people will miss it right okay so
clarity is super super super important
so that's where the meditation the
prayer the devotion helps me
to gain clarity
to deal with myself as an instrument of
change
to then also be able to be a better
listener as we talked about earlier to
the client that's talking to me how
about the mindset for you going into the
next event or next session with a client
where maybe something happened
i use myself as an example on our before
we came here yes my car was robbed yes i
lost my wallet my driver's license my
six debit cards all of my gear from my
workshops and presentations everything
gone
thousands and thousand dollars worth of
stuff plus headache all gone now we
gotta go drive to tim story and do a ten
part series
so
what would you do in that kind of
situation where you had something
negative happen to you maybe just now
and then 10 minutes later you have to
jump into a session so number one
i get i give
you and your family credit
for how you handled it
okay thank you again you gotta
understand i'm in my 50s you're younger
than me
so
you
you tell me the story right
then how did i respond to you was i
compassionate absolutely like for a long
time right yeah absolutely yeah okay
do you need anything
what can we do
like oh wow
like let's take a while to transition
but you you guys transition so quickly
and a lot of it is because of your
mindset
your mindset was
at least i'm still alive right
nobody got injured
they didn't take it all
that's your mindset so your mindset
helped you get through
the dilemma which was super super
powerful okay so i commend you thank you
on that
so here's what's very very important
anybody can learn from this whether
you're a life coach
or you're a mother a father
somebody dealing with somebody that's in
a crisis
is that
clarity is so important
so what i feel like you did is you
realize your loss
you saw tim's story you came in my house
you kind of like
shook yourself
you turn the page
and then you just kept going forward
okay
to get the right mindset you got to
shake it off
and you got to sometimes just turn the
page
it's the this too shall pass
that's powerful stuff don't you think i
love it i love the visual too
that turn the page yeah you turn the
page
so at this point it it doesn't almost
feel like you like you lost every thing
right this second right because we're so
in this flow right yeah okay so
life is going to give you the grace to
handle the loss
after these great interviews
and that's a beautiful thing about your
life see you you're you're a person of
faith so grace fills in the gaps
we all go through crap we don't like but
grace fills in the gaps
so that's having the proper mindset what
do you recommend for your clients
to do on a daily basis
you have your practice you have your
your devotion you have your workout
do you guide your clients through a
process if you're at a routine in the
morning that sets them up for success i
think that they should get the tim story
app the utmost app on itunes okay
because i do have an app
so i have an app that walks you through
seven days of your week
of how to be strong mentally
spiritually emotionally physically and i
even have meditations on this app so
it's called the utmost app with tim's
story
but
for my clients i give them a lot of
books to read there's a really good book
called quiet i don't know if you've ever
read that book
it's it's about being still
and being okay with being still
see we have become human doings this is
a temp story scene
rather than human beings and i'm i'm
telling you we're missing it man
have you noticed how still i am yeah
i'm like right i'm just like bam
like i'm just looking at all your power
i'm not like oh what's next i'm right
here
so i'm super still
my mindset
my mindset i tell you
is like i say this way
a magical mindset
is your vip pass anywhere
there's nowhere i can't get into with
this
this
has got me
everywhere
and do you think that that process that
you go through of training whether it's
the devotion in the gym or the the seven
steps in your app
are they mostly universal like everybody
needs quiet time everybody needs to go
work out or they're 100
universal you're gonna use them for
different things okay
if a woman has six kids or a man has six
children
so you're gonna use all that to handle
having six children
if a man's working two shifts he's gonna
use it for that
if a man is steve harvey
then he's going to use what i'm saying
for being steve harvey so depending on
your obligations
and the way you do life
is how you use those but it's all
universal but everybody needs quiet time
everybody man we were we were made to be
quiet we don't do well unless we're
quiet we were made to sleep without the
television on
we were made to drive sometimes with no
radio on
we were made to stop look and listen and
download beautiful thoughts
from heaven
is your devotional quiet time my
devotional is quiet time i call it i
call it the holy ground versus the
battleground okay the world is the
battleground okay so you're just minding
your own business and then they they
steal from your car right that's the
battleground
okay on a lighter version
we could go to a restaurant later
tonight
and the server may be in a bad mood
and act funny that's the battleground
okay
so the battleground is just life all the
stuff that life's thrown at you you need
to go to the holy ground the holy ground
is that place of quiet
where you get secrets where you feel
safe
where you feel significant
and to me where i'm hearing from god
so my holy ground is my strength for my
battleground
see i don't answer everybody's call
because
my my phone's ringing right now
because everybody
is having an urgent or somebody's having
an urgent somewhere
but they're urgent according to stephen
covey their urgent is not necessarily my
urgent
so thank god for that caller id stuff
i don't even have a number on my cell
phone
uh
that's amazing so we all need quiet time
minimum
what do you think mindset it depends on
the person like i need a lot because i'm
i go through a lot so i'm like an hour
of day
of just like boom i mean i'm in the
trenches but that's why i'm
so you'll wake up and do an hour of day
of devotional in the morning first thing
like a machine
eleven and then and then come out like a
machine okay i go to the gym i'm already
a machine before i hit the machines
because of the quiet time you had like
yes
interesting yeah and i and i get all
these calls from overseas and like i
could see like urgent urgent urgent no i
can't do that because if i don't get
filled up i got nothing to give
and is there anything else that people
need to be doing on a daily basis to get
the mindset well if they can't just sit
at home and get the mindset
driving their car
with no music on
or driving the car with meditation music
on
and just and just flow
okay
whether you're quietly praying or just
meditating however you do life
but just do that you can also do it by
listening to like a book
like getting one of these books that
we're talking about and listening to a
book on tape and you're listening and
you're you're meditating and you're
pondering you're thinking you're
muttering that's meditation
so you know
the bible says as a man thinketh so is
he
so no wonder i'm so dog unclear
because i choose
to watch what i think about i'm very
very careful
i don't listen to a bunch of negative
stuff
if somebody's speaking negative
i just i kind of zone out
and would you call your devotional
prayer
for me it is
because that's my faith
so
my my my devotional is a prayer life
that i have to god
but also
i'm studying like psalms proverbs
ecclesiastes
so like psalms 23 the lord is my
shepherd i shall not want the word want
in the hebrew means i shall not have
anxious desire so i'll meditate on that
and i'll say
thank you god that today i will not have
an anxious desire that no matter what
comes my way i will not be anxious no
matter what takes place no matter what
people say to me no matter what people
do to me i will not be anxious so
someone can come to me and say oh my god
i googled you and somebody said
something naked about you i go oh that's
all right they'll be okay
and i mean it
but you should see what they said no
that's okay they'll be okay they go no
they said about you i said that's okay
they'll be okay
but i really mean it
because i'm that into what the lord is
my shepherd i shall not have anxious
desire
so i choose not to have anxious desire
it's my choice if we pull on that thread
a little bit more faith
uh james 1 5 and 6 talks about how
you get wisdom from god yes so it's not
just praying for forgiveness or praying
for blessings or gratitude but wisdom
perfect so in your time of meditation
that's a great scripture in your time of
prayer and meditation
if any man lack wisdom let him ask of
god right and so that's what's happening
god's downloading wisdom let me just
tell you something
me and you
are living beyond our pay grade
okay
we're you're going to make a lot of
money i'm going to make a lot of money
our families are going to be blessed
they're going to be blessed three
generations down that's just the way
it's going to be okay
but
i need god's wisdom to do what i do
i'm i'm just
what i have to deal with every day is so
up here
i need his wisdom but he gives it to me
so do you pray for wisdom every morning
i i don't pray for wisdom every morning
because i haven't talked to you about
that that was a good scripture you
reminded me of but i pray and i get
wisdom
but now that you've reminded me of that
i'm going to pray for wisdom as well all
right there we go
so you thumb that up he just added to my
life
i love it come back tomorrow and we'll
see he's even wiser if that's possible
uh and and for people who aren't
religious yeah what's what is what's the
meditation what's the process well if
they were gonna spend an hour what are
they doing in that hour well a lot of
people are not religious and they're
doing great you know they're just
they're just being quiet
so it could be a walk on the beach
right
some guys are surfers that i know
just being out there surfing some people
do yoga
some people are running and they're just
in a in a zone i think it's more
about it's more about being quiet
but the great thing about prayer
to this amazing powerful god
is that the god who created me is
downloading heavy information so i'll go
that way
cool
today is episode seven how to have the
right business partners or just write
partners what are we going down with
this one well i think it's it's the
right partners in life like we're
partners but then you have to have the
right business partners as well so you
want me to explain that yeah yeah okay
so in anything that we do
so much emphasis is being on
being the right person so everybody's
like you know i'm vegan or you know i
don't eat meat
or exercise and you should be the right
person right
so you have to be the right person but
then people talk a lot about having the
right plan
but you could be the right person with
the right plan and have the wrong
partners and mess the whole thing up
okay so we're talking about tim's story
the life coach right
so i could be the right person
with the right plan and coaching in all
the things i do
steve harvey facebook
uh oprah winfrey stuff that i do
uh my one-on-one clients tv shows all
the stuff that i do right in coaching
right so i could be the right person
with the right plan
but have the wrong partners
and you know what's going to happen
i'm going to get paralyzed in that same
spot
so
i need to get around people
that are going to lift me up
and strengthen me to another level do
you mind if i use a
a bible verse yeah okay so the bible
says this
he who walks with the wise
will become even more wise himself
but a companion of fools his life will
unravel okay okay so you have 24 hours a
day
and i have 24 hours a day
so in your line of business in my line
of business
if we're not careful
we will have people
that do not have wisdom that will try to
come into our inner circle
and they will cause our life to begin to
unravel
but if i partner with somebody who's
wise
the bible says i will stack up more
wisdom
so in my 24 hours a day that i have
man i want to walk with the wise and i
want to become more wise i want to stack
up more wisdom so right person right
plan
got to stack up more wisdom
what do you suggest when the people who
are the fools who are unraveling you are
your parents
your best friends or your sister yes
okay so what you got to do you always
have to be friendly
fair
but sometimes firm
so it's a great book called
boundaries and so i i am i am a pro at
boundaries
i think i'm
i think i'm really good at boundaries
okay
and so
um
on the spiritual tip i got to go there
again
that the jesus had levels of partners
he had the one his father that he spoke
to then he had the three peter james and
john the sons of thunder
then he had the twelve in which peter
james and john were part of
then he had the seventy
to the one the father he told him
everything to the three he told them a
lot to the twelve he told him a lot to
the seventy he spoke in parables
it's very powerful right
so there are people that come into our
life
that are not supposed to know your
inside stuff
because
they may not be able to handle the truth
even if that's your mom
even though that's your mom
so
you're nice to your mom but you may
speak to her in parables
because she may say to you what are you
talking about this tour you're going on
why so many cities
make sense
but you know you're supposed to do it so
you respect her
you're friendly
you're fair
but you're firm and your own convictions
and you're like oh yeah you know mom
that's an interesting way
of looking at it and then you book las
vegas
and powerful stuff would you recommend
then just
avoiding topics that you know will
trigger because there's got to be still
enough if it's your mom or your friend
there's enough love there on other
topics you talk about almost anything
else except for this thing that you know
is going to cause conflict okay so we're
talking about the right partners yeah
and we'll and we'll keep it on this
whole life coaching thing okay
but
i'm a coach you're a coach but we still
have lives
so
the family that we have
like they say you don't pick your family
you're born in to the family so i got to
deal with family dynamics
but that doesn't mean i'm going to tell
all my family members what i'm really
thinking
because just because you're my family
doesn't mean you're in my three or my 12
you might be in my 70 so i'm going to
speak to you in parables
so they may say say to me man so so what
did kanye say to you i heard did he talk
to you about something i'll go well you
know he's a good guy and um we talked
about his new music i'm not going to
tell them
because they're going to go tell
somebody else right
makes sense
and so
i think again we're always friendly
we're always fair
but we're still firm in our con in our
convictions
and and knowing that not everybody's
going to get you
here's another way of saying it
you cannot get a fm radio station on an
am dial
somebody
that was raised with you
may have understood you at 15 but they
don't understand you now
make sense yeah no i hear you so if you
tell them all your dreams
they're not on the same frequency as you
on the business side of things
who are the types of partners that you
need to have success as a life coach
okay here's the great thing about
partnering with people i don't know
richard branson
but i can watch his ted talk
i don't know richard branson but i could
read his biography
that's powerful stuff right
i don't know margaret thatcher she's not
around but i could read the biography i
don't know winston churchill never give
up guy but i could read all these things
about his life and watch
documentaries about him so this is a
beautiful thing about life
there's certain things i don't know i
can go to your youtube channel and find
out now
so i can partner with you
and you may never even meet me
it's beautiful it's a beautiful thing
i go all over the world 75 countries i
was in turkey not too long ago
this guy runs at me to me i'm in
istanbul
and he's like hey tim story oh my god
i'm like your biggest fan he was like
quoting me left and right never met the
guy he's in istanbul right but
he's partnering with me because he
watches me
so so that's a mentorship kind of
partnership
well yeah i mean it's they could they
could now read our books
hear us speak
hear a podcast
watch you on youtube
and we don't all have to be best buddies
you could just take things that pertain
to your life but i do not believe that
you could be a great life coach
unless you have the right partners in
your life
so i am constantly having to elevate my
coaching skills
because of the type of people i coach
so when you have one of the presidents
like a former president
who reads your book like he read mine
as his devotional
for months
so so the type of coaching i do
is it's such an interesting level i
better have some access to some people
that could give me some advice from time
to time
and so where do you see as your next
phase of partnerships i guess who else
do you need to be partnering with you
okay great no i'm i learn from people
see i love pharrell williams and he's
always cool with me
but pharrell
he talks about being a sponge
i'm a sponge
i'm learning from everybody that's in
this room
so from you today i see
i see that mindset of yours okay
i see your your education
i see you're from canada but yet i don't
see you're from canada does that make
sense so they're like there's so many
sides of you
that i'm i'm i'm learning
i'm learning how you do
uh this this this broadcast that we're
doing today you're very like disciplined
so i'm i'm learning i'm learning from
you
so when i leave you today and you leave
me
i just look i just took a part of you
thanks
no doubt great so if i'm with quincy
jones i took a part of him if i'm with
you it took part of you quincy jones
said one of my favorite lines of all
time give it to me not one drop of my
self-worth comes from your opinion of me
okay
you can't beat that
jones
has been such an important part of my
life he's the one that nicknamed me the
voice okay
he says that tim's story is a voice of
encouragement of our generation and then
he doesn't play around he's the one that
gave
the label to michael jackson the king of
pop
and i asked quincy jones one time i said
how come
some people with one hit don't have more
hits
and i'll never forget it was like 1208
at night because he likes to stay up
late
because i remember i looked at the clock
i thought i better go and then i asked
him that question he stood up
he goes little brother it's one of the
best questions you've ever asked
he said
because
there were more hits underneath
but
they didn't
have it in them to dig and dig and dig
and dig
most people are satisfied living off the
one hit
and then he grabbed me because
don't be satisfied living off the one
hit dig and dig and dig and that
powerful
can't be satisfied man
gotta dig i love it gotta have the right
partners that's what we're talking about
what are some other powerful questions
you've asked
to you or to quincy anybody
uh
a good a good thing that i learned from
lee iacocca coco was like richard
branson before branson jeff bezos before
bezos
is
about this thing about
pace and speed and everybody
trying to do it all now
iacocca says to me
it's not how fast you move your feet
it's how big your strides are
bam
game over
i love it so someone who's starting out
trying to be a life coach
trying to figure out who the right
partners are for them know that there's
another gear inside them that they're
not hitting yet yeah
and then and then pay attention to the
people you resonate with if you resonate
with tim's story follow me
if you resonate with yana vanzant follow
her if you resonate with brene brown pay
attention to her so whoever
you connect with
pay attention to them
learn from them
but again as we talked about in an
earlier segment you've been born in
original don't die a copy
so mimic us at first and then
your own fresh style will emerge how
important do you think on that topic do
you think it is to
try to learn from the person who you
don't immediately connect with
because if i look at you or janla or
oprah or eric thomas or a bunch of other
people yeah
it's the same messages
similar similar messages yes totally
different style and tone yes you know
eric thomas is gonna yell at you through
everything yes and oprah's gonna hug you
through everything yes
you will resonate with one over the
other how important is it in your mind
to try to learn from the other person
it's so important if your strategy
hang out with passion if your passion
hang out with strategy most of the
people i study
are not from where i come from i come
from like la deep la
most people i study are like from europe
from south africa
they're brainiacs
they were raised a certain way
so a lot of the people that people often
say about me if you put all tim stories
friends in a room
you would not understand how this all
happened
because i have like some of the coolest
nerdiest friends and then i hang out
with rap stars
you're a wild duck
i love it who who who are you partnering
with now who's who are you messing with
who you trying to learn from you
mentioned mother teresa is one of your
early mentors yeah i mean i'm reading
about mother tree so i never got a
chance to hang out with her
but
um
i mean come on man
let's let's talk about being in the
studio with kanye west when he was doing
the song stronger
all he had was a beat
to do
whatever doesn't kill me makes me
stronger to go from that to then say i'm
going to put strings on it to then say
i'm going to bring in timberland to help
me
to then pharrell williams to come in and
say man if i was you i'd change it this
way to them will i am say ooh that's
cool but if i was you i do it this way
to see
the beginning of stronger and then to
see
how so many people
were affected by that song
just even by the hook
whatever doesn't make me
kill me makes me stronger
i learned
just in sitting in that and i remember
one time i told kanye i said man if i
was you i would put this in because i'm
pretty good with words he goes he goes
tim that's why you're not a rapper
what's the team's story version of that
song
it was thrown out man he just he didn't
want to hear it
i love it i'm here with the legend mr
tim's story this is part eight and we're
talking about marketing now tim you are
the force gump
of this industry you are the the the
wild duck the weird bird that seems to
have it all kind of figured out people
coming to you a-list celebrities
athletes
how do people do it how do you become
that magnet for great clients you know
the interesting thing is and that's why
i need your help on this subject
is because
the way most people marketed themself
to become really really good at what
they do
like if if i was to go through facebook
or if i look at instagram i see a lot of
ads from like really good guys i won't i
won't name their names but i see all
these ads
if you go through facebook instagram
you're not gonna see these tim story ads
but yet
look at the reach i have
from tv shows to movies to plays
speaking to
75 countries
getting upwards to 2000 invitations a
year
so
how did it happen
that's what i'm asking you though right
i mean
the way i see it is you just go in and
you provide
insane value that people want to talk
about you and they want to spread the
message and they want to have you come
back and totally you totally gave the
answer okay so the answer to me
is value
so i remember one time i was gonna go to
rome
so a friend of mine said to me
oh man you got to go to this restaurant
and so he gave me the name of the
restaurant and i kind of thought it
would be like in the beverly hills part
of rome
almost by the spanish steps there yeah
and
we just kept going down and down and
down and
i mean
it was like all these curves and then it
looked like a little house
but this was this restaurant that
everybody wanted to go to because of
this
amazing chef
but i i thought about something that
this guy was so good at making food
that we went down all these twists and
turns just
to eat his food
that's how i wanted to be as a coach
i want to have such value
right
that you got to try to find them you
know there was a time
about five years ago i knocked my whole
website out on purpose
so you know i'm timstory.com i knocked
it out
for two years on purpose
just so people couldn't find me easy
and it worked
because sometimes mystery is what people
are looking for
isn't that interesting
no do i believe in marketing yes do i
believe in taking out ads
yes okay do i believe in funnels if
they're good yes
but also believe in what prince did as
an artist
so you never saw like prince as an
artist
marketing himself on facebook or
instagram he was mysterious
so prince could say
to people
i'm playing at
12 midnight
on february 14th at the house of blues
you'd see madonna in the front row
justin timberlake this is all true story
gwen stefani
biggest models stevie wonder why
his value was so great
you'd show up at 12 midnight
boom because it was prince
so i think value is what's driven people
to me and to you
how did how did you get your first
client
first client
came from
this is an interesting one i was in
seminary
and
a friend of mine asked me to speak at a
rotc group
i was a sophomore in seminary
and i was not a speaker yet
and so
uh i said you know i don't really know
what to say
and he helped me with some notes and i
went i was really funny
so
they said can you come back
and so i started going back and so it
was it was every tuesday to speak to
this group it kind of shocked me
when every time they'd give me an
envelope and it had a 50 check that said
tim's story because i never did it for
the money
but they gave me 50
so that was good when you're young
because then you can buy gas and you
know do your laundry
but then something happened to me where
i got a break
as i got just a little bit older
i was speaking somewhere and reggie
white was there reggie white was a
famous football player for the
philadelphia eagles at one time and he
was there and he saw me
and he said hey man i like you he goes i
want to start booking you in chapels
to motivate nfl players i'm in my 20s
reggie white the reggie white starts
booking tim's story and all these
chapels now this is how the life
coaching started this is so cool see
some things in life you decide
other things you discover okay
so when i would speak at these chapels
when i'd get done guys would come up and
go hey man
can i get your phone number
i'd like to hook up with you so some of
the biggest stars in the nfl i'm in my
20s started asking me for my number
i started coaching before i realized i
was coaching
isn't that cool
they started paying me
before i realized
that i was in the business of coaching
so i i think that
it was one of those things because you
know i love the the bible a man's gift
makes room for him and brings him before
great men
but let's go back to
standard approaches of marketing because
as you said i'm a bit of a forest gump
okay
i do believe in the way a lot of my
buddies market
like a grant cardone he needed to fill
up a stadium
in miami he had billboards he had
marketing
he had cross promotion you know even i
had a commercial for him so a lot of
people
you know cross-promoted because we love
him and so you know he had like about 35
000 people
and you got to market at times
and so i i believe in marketing but i
believe in in in marketing
and making sure you're fishing
in the right
watch pond
make sure you're fishing in the right
pond does that make any sense yeah
absolutely what does that mean to you to
fish in the right pond you have to be
targeting the right people exactly right
ideal clients what was super interesting
for me was
your entire marketing strategy seemed to
revolve around
your very first
speaking gigs yes getting paid 50 bucks
a time and the key thing that came back
to me the words that you said were
we want you to come back
yes because we want you to value we want
you to come back so i would say most
places i've ever been invited i get
invited back over and over and over and
over
a lot of people that i coach because i
do one-on-one coaching the reason i have
a line to coach
with me is because the same people keep
signing up
i have some people that i've been
coaching for 25 years
and i don't coach them every week
some of them i coach like every other
week or once a month but very powerful
people who run beverly hills but i guess
i must be offering
value
in a service that they need
they want you to come back yes people
just keep wanting you to come back yeah
but i do believe in marketing yeah
but strategic marketing
and understanding
who your client is
again i'm a good comeback coach
if you if you need a comeback
call me
so if i'm a life coach
i want to build my brand i want to get
new clients i don't necessarily want to
sell at a stadium of 35 000 people right
fishing in the right pond that's not my
pond if i'm a life coach yeah
how do you recommend i go about starting
to market my services i think one thing
is is to do things
for free for a period of time a lot of
people don't like this
but i really do believe
in in giveaways
do you know that
several writers
that have had best-selling books
they never went out to have a
best-selling book
they wrote a book
created like an e-book and send it to
like 20 friends
just as i care i want to bless you
the friends saw it and went holy schmoly
guacamole i can name
a few but i'm not going to
same thing with coaching
as you if you're working on your brand
coach a few people for free
and then they'll be the happy ones and
then they'll tell a friend and so on and
so on and so on word of mouth is super
super powerful
most of the the celebrities i have which
i life coach
right around 300 celebrities and people
say how do you do all of them i don't do
them all at once
it's it's word of mouth
it's they didn't
necessarily see me on oprah or steve
harvey or something it's usually word of
mouth
how many people could you take on at
once
i have a lot
but i have a lot of energy
we know that
but we got a lot like what's what's the
upper first for life coach watching yes
what's a what's up what's a higher end
number of people
that you think somebody should be able
to manage somebody if somebody is
coaching
in one day i think five clients
a day
is enough
at one hour right
because i think you you should coach
there needs to be a small break you
should coach it needs to be a small
break
you definitely need to as we talked
about earlier you need to turn the page
for a second right
and so i know coaches that like coach
eight hours straight a clients
man you almost need somebody to like
shovel you off
and take you to the next destination
it's it can be exhausting
especially with what you're dealing with
yeah i mean
i'm dealing with some heavy-duty stuff
that can really change somebody's life
like you know you know some people i
coach i mean i've been with like some of
the most famous celebrities in the world
and the next day
they're gonna go
on national tv and talk about a huge
dilemma right i mean i can name two guys
like that right now
when i say guys it could be one could be
a man one could be a woman
but i better like be fresh
eight hours of coaching straight is not
gonna make me fresh
and how important do you think the
branding of you being the comeback
guy has been to your success changed my
life okay change my life and
you want to know how that happened yeah
so i was playing golf with a sports
agent okay and another friend who's a
producer
and i missed a putt i'm a golfer i'm
going to palm springs to golf i'm
leaving tonight
so i missed the putt and the guy goes
like this you had a setback that's the
truth because we were playing
competitive and i go i did
but i'm not going to take a step back
and i said in fact i'm not going to sit
in my setback i'm not going to settle in
my setback and i'm not going to cement
myself in my setback and then the guy
goes have you ever said that before i go
no i said in fact when i'm feeling the
sting of my setback life is about to
give me my comeback and the guy goes
oh my god you're on fire he goes write
it down that's how i started the
comeback teaching
this was in the late 80s and i went and
started writing it down on my little
scorecard
and so we had like five more holes to go
i literally wrote
all 12 chapter titles
while i was on this freaking
changed my life wow
that statement
changed my life could you imagine being
like
on super supe super soul sunday with
oprah right
and then you know you hug her you're in
santa barbara you've seen her show
and then you sit down
and she's my buddy so i don't know what
she's gonna talk to me about but she
sits down and she she has my comeback
and beyond book and she goes oh my god i
love what you say in page 67 i'm like oh
my gosh my life is changing oprah is
holding my book for one hour
it all started on the golf course you
got to hang around that buddy of yours
from the golf course more often exactly
so marketing marketing for you is
important marketing for me is important
marketing for me now is for me to keep
being tim's story
love it to to to go through airports and
still be the guy that's high-fiving
people
loving people
you know wherever i am still being that
guy that's marketing because it's word
of mouth it's like hey he he come he
came from here but now he lives this way
but he's still cool
that's marketing this episode is number
nine on how to price your services
what advice do you have for us man this
is a good one pricing
okay so
if i go to kohl's target or walmart okay
i can get a t-shirt at a good price
right
if i go to dolce gabbana
if i go to armani it's going to be a
little pricey right
and the interesting thing about it
the more i'm learning about clothing
is that the quality
may just be a little bit different
so you you're basically paying for the
brand
your your pain for the name
and so i find with pricing
that
you should really take your time before
you go to those high prices i find so
many new coaches
okay
they see coaches like myself or others
that have been around for a long time
i've been doing it over 20 years right
and then they try to hit the pricing
that we're at and they get frustrated
i think first you have to prove your
value
okay
and by proving your value
by somebody's life being changed they're
making better decisions and having a
better life than manifesting greater
things
then what happens
they start to talk about your services
and then your pricing can then go up
so we talked in the last episode about
doing work for free at the beginning
just to build your brand build the
marketing
is it just trying to get as many people
you're just trying to touch as many
people get the practice in get the reps
in get better
try to do as many as you can without
burning out and yeah
just to get word of mouth going and then
you start charging yeah and i i think
that it's it's not even just as many
it's the quality okay so so let me life
coach you so so let's say if you were a
favorite if you were a new life coach
okay
so you come to tim's story and and i
said hey what's your background you say
well i went to usc
and i have a psychology degree and i go
oh that's that's good so we could use
that in your curriculum so first you
have to form
a
curriculum so you you create your own
curriculum maybe borrow from others
uh but make sure you let people know
you're borrowing from from other people
so i'll say to you um do you have any
clients no
all right so let's advertise
free life coaching
but we're only going to do this
for three months okay okay
so let's take on like
eight clients a week
for absolutely free
keep your day job
don't just go full time coaching keep
your day job that's very smart
coach for free
then you say to these people your
coaching for free
if this has been beneficial to you
i'm now starting to charge
to coach
this is my fee
i guarantee you because i know this
because i do this
many of the people not all but many of
the people are going to stay on with you
because now you've hooked them because
you're good at what you do so one way is
now i'm a paid service
okay
i've been doing this just because i'm
growing in this but i'm adding value to
your life so now
we're charging the second thing is if
i've added value to your life can you
think of two people that you can tell
about my services
so i'm going to send you a text or an
email that you could forward
that's how people start building
okay it's very similar to speakers i say
this to speakers if you go speak at a
seminar
and the people like you like let's say
if you go speak for nike and the guy at
nike goes oh my god you're the best i've
ever had okay since you think i'm the
best you have a lot of friends in the
space of leadership if you could think
of two friends if you could send my
information that would really help
that's another way to market and get
your brand out there
i love it
for for structure
how often do you think somebody needs to
be life coached
yes is that a weekly thing a monthly
well here's the deal so one of the
popular things is bundles
so and i do believe in bundles but you
got to make sure you have a curriculum
[Music]
that
people want to buy a bundle of that
curriculum right
so i'm not a one-off life coach
so we have bundles
of like five coaching sessions with
tim's story
but you have to understand
i have 60 different lessons that i've
created
with
three psychologists member and one
psychiatrist
so i got 60 different lessons and
they're fantastic
that you got to fill out paperwork and
everything so i'm i'm taking you
somewhere so that bundle of five
that's just the beginning
most people then get hooked
because by
session three or four i'm already
talking to them about sessions six seven
and eight and where i'm going to take
you
so some people do one-offs i like
bundles better
because bundles is like harry potter the
beginning harry potter two harry potter
three harry potter 27.
[Laughter]
so when you when you're figuring out
pricing the pricing but then also
also in thinking about how often
somebody needs to come back so bundle of
five for your client to get the results
you want them to come back because
they're getting results they found value
in what you're you're giving them
what what is a frequency that actually
makes sense like if somebody's being
life coached once a month is that enough
to get results depends on the goal okay
okay so
you have different areas of your life as
you know i'm just going to tell you what
you know
physical
mental spiritual
social life you have a social life
you have a job
okay
you have a family so there's there's
different areas of your life
so i might be really coaching somebody
in the job
part of his life this is a lot of what i
do
but then somebody's daughter may act up
so i've gone from the job
to the daughter and the job
and then their health may act up so i've
gone from the job to the daughter and
the health
you see that
so that's what usually happens to me
is that
while i'm coaching a client
other areas of their life
will begin
to have a need
and now i'm coaching from one area
to all seven areas of their life and
they need to increase their frequency to
get there not necessarily some people i
coach every week some people i coach
every other week
but i i find that the
every other week for the people that
really need help
that that's
that's a good
uh time frame
i don't like it to be like
once a month because there's a lot that
can happen in 30 days
so
most people that i coach i coach once a
week
or every other week and i keep them on
track got it
for people who then are thinking of
raising their prices
who've gotten some results for their
clients they have a steady roster maybe
they're charging 100 bucks an hour and
they want to go to two are you calls are
you target
are you walmart you got to be realistic
about the value that you're bringing
if you if you feel like you're a
boutique
and you are like walking into a great
store in beverly hills and rodeo drive
and it's a dolce gabbana if you're dolce
gabbana then raise your prices
but you gotta you gotta be realistic so
when i first started with those nfl guys
they were trying to give me a lot of
money i wouldn't take it all
because i wasn't dolce gabbana
this is good right
and was it the mindset that you weren't
there or you just didn't have the skills
i didn't have i didn't i didn't have the
i didn't have the mindset
i didn't have the curriculum and i did
not have the experience
today i'm dropping all three
chopping bombs yeah come on man better
but come on i've been at it a long time
yeah
so it's it's like somebody who can cook
you know somebody can really cook
and they they go in a kitchen they can
go in almost any kitchen and make
something happen
this is what i do i can do it in the
back of a rap concert i could do it at
an nba game
i could talk somebody out of doing
something crazy
i can do it in a prison i do i do this
in every setting you can imagine
because i've been doing it so long and i
have that skill set
so i think just be honest about
your skill set
and your experience and then
look at what other people are charging
and then also again remember we talked
about motives just make sure your
motives are right
make sure your motives are right
charge because you feel like
your
service is that valuable
and that you want somebody to appreciate
your value i don't have a problem with
that what about the people who actually
should be charging more but they're
afraid of
getting rejected they're afraid that
their clients may not be able to afford
it they're they're talking themselves
down but they actually have the ability
to do it well some people do it in the
air for the reason of humanitarian
efforts
and they're they're they're counseling
and helping people for humanitarian
reasons or spiritual reasons or
religious reasons right so that's fine
but if if it is your
way of making a living
that
if your friends and your partners are
saying hey what you do is valuable so
like with you with what you know about
youtube
and everything you're doing how many
followers roughly
getting close to two million uh about
two million that's a lot okay
so to spend an hour with you if i'm just
a client
i i better i better have a big stack and
then you need to go bam
yeah yeah without taking your stack yeah
then
then you can get a grill
you get a diamond grill
yeah no no i have people i have people
that show up to me with like a sack of
money
and sometimes i take it if they have if
they have more sacks
right it depends on the person
and how do you know when
to still
give back and you do a lot of work for
free still so much of my stuff is for
free i'm a humanitarian i'm in third
world nations all the time
speaking in schools
orphanages for free
because i love it all the stuff we're
doing with the prisoners you know i'm
involved with the prison system helping
with
a bunch of people with a great group
called arc arc the stuff i'm doing from
melrose recovery which we're helping
addicts i'm doing for free
come on
man gotta give back
what a privilege
what a privilege to like have this
information to give back right sure
and so so making that decision for the
person who wants to give back and be
humanitarian
because they had they had the right
motives but they're also afraid to
charge more and they need it to be able
to build a business and hire a team and
scale yeah that dilemma of i know i'm
worth it but i feel like i should be
charging more yeah so in that case i
would say if people are paying and they
think you're dolce gabbana or prada
gucci christian louboutin
take the money
and then take a portion of it and give
it away
and could the portion of the money also
be like portion of your time 100 so it's
a portion of the money or the portion of
the time so if if you're that great
and people want to give it take the
money
right
and then you can use a lot of that for
charity that's what a lot of i won't
name drop my buddies right now but a lot
of great coaches that i know and you
know
they give a lot of money away
robin hood yeah
yeah so i'm blessed to be a blessing i'm
glad that i'm blessed i am blessed
you're blessed i'm blessed to be a
blessing that's where i'm coming from
love it this is our last episode with
tim's story on how to build a successful
life coaching business today episode 10
talking about balance
what do you got for us is it possible to
have balance i'm asking you oh man
you're the life coach
yes it's possible to have balance
i don't want to upset tim's story my
gosh you could have balance
okay so
we've talked about it a little bit
before you have your physical life your
spiritual life
your mental which is like your clarity
you have your family
you have your financial your job
okay but what's very very very important
is that we have
balance in all this some people say you
can't have balance success i believe you
can
i don't believe that you should be like
super successful in your job and your
body's falling apart
are your bodies like rock solid and you
have no clarity of mind
so i'm i'm all about balance
i actually take
days off
i actually go on vacation and i'm not on
my phone all the time and see a lot of
the guys i coach are like big crybabies
okay because when you coach the mighty
they think they need you right now and
you better answer right now
so i was recently just in spain okay
so i'm enjoying myself i was laughing
because i was getting all these texts
from powerful people and they were like
tim please i know you're on vacation
just two minutes but it's not even
something that important
if somebody was like you know
in dire straits no this is like
questions about
little business moves they're doing
they're just spoiled
so no matter how spoiled they are
i do not answer everybody's urgent
because i believe
in balance i believe in slowing down to
the rhythm of life and how much of
balance is personal like tim's story's
version of balance will be different
than somebody else's how much of a
variance you think there is so a lot of
it is what's your priority
so my priority is i want to live life
so i believe that god gave you and me a
gift of life
the greek word for life is zoe as you
know which is a god kind of life with a
skip in your step and a glide in your
stride
little timmy's story with my big afro as
a kid i was alive
me in my mid 50s look at me i'm still
alive
i am alive i i can still dance
i sing even though i'm not a good singer
are you with me i'll do karaoke on
occasion
i love movies i love documentaries i
like cracking up with my friends kids
i am so i'm i'm as alive as i was when i
was 10 years of age
so i choose
life
so that is my priority to live my
priority is not just success
you know
getting to the next place i'm living
out of my living i am successful out of
my living i am prosperous out of my
living i'm a good father et cetera et
cetera et cetera
so what's the process for you of helping
somebody find what balance looks like to
them because i think there's a tendency
to look at somebody's life on instagram
or on youtube and they see one side and
you want that from this person and then
you judge yourself against
what time they wake up yeah like well
they're waking up at four and then
hustling and grinding at work so i
should do that too even though it may
not be the best fit for you yeah and
then you feel insecure that you're not
able to keep up with that person and
that thing and this person and this
thing and and then just you feel worse
about yourself i think a lot of it is is
a personality type okay okay so i am an
artist okay so i can actually write
songs
i can draw i can paint i design jewelry
i play around with designing clothes
i write plays i write movies i create tv
shows so i'm an artist
all my speeches i create myself
so many tim storyism one-liners i
created them all
and so i'm an artist
so i'm not the guy that is
in uh you know on purpose
gonna say i'm gonna beat the sun up
i don't have like that military
background of i'm going to beat the sun
up right
the reason
i wake up at five in the morning
is just that's the time i wake up
so since i'm up
then i meditate i pray
i study
okay psalm proverbs ecclesiastes i feel
my spirit
okay
i get ready and i go to the gym
so i'm in the gym at about 6 15.
i'm in there from 6 15
to about 7 30.
i shower
and i'm already coaching at about 8 30.
so i'm already flowing so if that's on
my grind
so that's on my artistic grind
and do you keep that up when you're
traveling you're about to head off to
play some golf palm springs
yes i will wake i will wake up early on
accident
and i will do similar things
so the the reason that i exercise
about six days a week
is because i used to wake up i feel
depressed
and is as much energy as i have
i was talking to smokey robinson about
this because smokey's like my brother
and then and he says he says man tim
this used to happen to me
because you go from the high of
performing
to all of a sudden this down you come
down does that make sense to you yeah
yeah for sure so i'd wake up and i'm mr
optimistic i wake up depressed
and he goes tim the thing that helped me
is
man you gotta exercise
so i i hit that treadmill
i exercise six out of seven days
and it just it just makes me feel so
much better and it's cardio overall
well i do i have a trainer and i do i do
free weights
and but i do lighter weights just to
stay toned
and then i um i do a lot of cardio but
that really helps my head space
yeah if you look at most of america i
don't think most people would
self-identify of living a balanced life
yes
i'm in the balance and you know i may i
may have to turn down sometimes
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars to like
go to my son's baseball game when he was
smaller
or go to my daughter's
ballet uh performance
whatever how much of that
is scheduling and just knowing hey i
need to i need to spend this amount of
time or i need to make sure i'm at that
baseball game or i need to make sure
that i'm spending time morning doing my
my prayer
versus
feeling you know what like i'm feeling a
little overwhelmed right now yeah in the
moment i need to take
an hour to myself and just relax so it's
it's it's a little both okay so
sometimes
um
[Music]
your body
and your mind
and your psyche is telling you you need
to rest
and sometimes it's just the discipline
of it okay
like for
instance i
intentionally i
live by my mother my mother is 87 years
of age
so she raised me when my father died
when i was 10 she had to raise you know
all her kids five children
working at a donut shop
so
um
you know my older sister she was married
so she had four at home but you know she
had five kids still to raise
so that's my mother
so i used to always be in beverly hills
that's where i lived that's where i
did all my stuff
and
i purposely came and rented a house
in in orange county where you are right
the second
and we turn this like into a studio
office
just to be close to my mother
and all my friends go like whoa
how come you're not just over there
i am over there but i'm also over here
because my mother lives down the street
so that's balance so i'm around my
mother a lot i'm in my 50s i hang out
with my mother sometimes it's my mother
that's balance but but you but you're
losing money
that's my mother so i don't really think
i'm losing money
so what's what's what's important
did donuts mean anything to you now huh
do donuts mean anything to you now i
love donuts still so so
about once every two weeks
i still sneak into a donut shop but i'm
so good with donuts because i've been on
donuts since i was a child
because she ran donut shops
i could take a bite of it and i could
tell how good the the baker is
and i could i could tell what kind of
flour they're using wow that's how good
i am with those what's your favorite
donut
uh
so
i love krispy kreme wow
because they just do them right just the
original the original they got them down
and when the hot sign is on i may make a
u-turn and go there
[Laughter]
but i believe in
balance
i believe in balance balance has made me
good at what i do
so it's a funny thing i was going to
speak at this big conference
and i was behind the scenes
and i was playing with this guy's kids
and his kids were joking with me because
i'd known him forever and the guy that
invited me literally came up and he goes
uh hey tim story uh uh um are you okay i
go yeah what do you mean
he goes you're gonna be up in like four
minutes
and i go yeah i'm miked
and he goes are you okay though i go
yeah what do you mean he goes i've seen
you on stage before and you're all hyped
up don't you need to hype yourself up i
go no i'm don't worry you'll see
because so many speakers like if they
speak to a big crowd they're like pacing
oh right have you ever seen that yeah
not me
no dude i'm like right here i'm in the
moment
i'm balanced i'm playing with somebody's
kids i'm high-fiving somebody i'm
answering somebody's question
i'm not uh cramming for a test
i'm ready
give me the bike
i like that i'm not coming for a test
give me the mic yo
bam fire
we set stage is on fire
what do you think is the most important
thing that america should do to get more
balance in their life uh part of it is
don't take yourself so doggone seriously
i think that
that
so many people
they're like on this they're on this
thing like uh oh man i said i gotta do
this by this age and uh i gotta do this
by that age
really
i think it's that thing that i teach on
as you know the law of the harvest you
gotta plow the ground every day i'm
hustling every day i'm hustling so i am
plowing tim's story story's plowing then
i'm planting seed then i'm watering seed
which is repetition and then i'm
breaking out harvest so right now i'm
breaking out all these harvests and
speaking for all these years i'm
breaking out harvest and life coaching
but now i'm in the broadway place i'm
working on a 25 million broadway play
that i helped create with my partner so
so i'm plowing plowing plowing learning
learning learning learning okay so
there's there's certain things that i'm
harvesting
but certain things i'm plowing
but every great farmer still has to rest
so i'm going to rest so i can be a
better plower planter and harvester
some people are so exhausted they don't
even know how to get their harvest
you know how powerful that is
it's powerful stuff
even lebron james takes time off in
games
lebron james
his coach is resting him
so he's at an optimum level at certain
times in the game i gotta rest
so i could be tim's story
yeah what do you recommend for somebody
who's
doing this part-time they got a family
they got a job they're coming home
they're now still trying to build their
business
but they're feeling pulled
in multiple directions and they're not
they're not gonna like this answer okay
you ready i'm ready but this is why i'm
good at what i do let's hear it okay so
if you wanted to do it all in 12 months
let's do it in 18 months
i want to i want to give you six months
of grace
if you want to do it two years let's do
it in two and a half years
as soon as i say that to people
all of a sudden all this you could just
see them like oh
i'm like what's
what are we chasing
like like i i watch people on freeways
sometimes where they're like just
cutting people
i'm like
is he rushing home to lay down on his
couch
are you you get my point yeah are you
rushing home to get home to your nagging
husband
like slow down man
listen to some cool music and just chill
so i mean
i'm doing a lot you know i got all this
stuff going on
but there's a time and place for
everything
so sometimes i'm like
sixth gear of a porsche
sometimes i'm cruising in third gear so
right now me and you are just cruising
dropping wisdom changing lives
watching you go to almost
2 million then you're going to be 3
million and 4 million and still
hopefully be my buddy
so we're living balanced life living a
balanced life is awesome i love life man
i love life i'm into life life is good
cool man appreciate the feedback it's a
different perspective than what most
people are preaching
so i love you sharing the wisdom thank
you very much cool 10 episodes down man
people want to dive deeper into your
world where do you want them to go uh
timstory.com but i'm s-t-o-r-e-y
so tim
and then s-t-o-r-e-y
[Music]
and people can life coach with me
and there is a line but it's worth the
wait don't you think some things are
worth the wait some things are yeah and
you got your app so we got an app
called the utmost app that they can get
right now on itunes they can download it
so life coaching with tim's story then
we got an app
and then also
my instagram is tim story
official love it we'll link all of that
down in the description below tim's
story thank you for the love man life is
good
to learn how to build a million dollar
restaurant business check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there 90 of restaurants in new york
never see an anniversary wow
some percentage of them never open their
doors wow and it's uh
if i'm off i'm off slightly it's a
horrific number